If you look at the history of there, our space programs,
both Russian and American, you're going to find some pretty weird stuff. Pretty,
pretty weird history there, ALEKS. Um, so you want to get an idea,
go back to [inaudible] and read a little bit about what he has to say.
If you look back at the history of our space programs,
the viable space programs are both Russian and American and each
has an amazingly strange history because, uh,
the founders of the calculations that got us up into space,
the rocket scientists basically were doing some pretty weird rituals and doing
religious things, right. They weren't necessarily like Jack Parsons on our side,
I was out in the desert with people like L Ron Hubbard and doing really
intense rituals,
believing that they were opening stargates and things like that. Okay.
And they were really doing that. Okay. So then you go to, um,
the Russian side and they had a very specific
non-dogmatic according to Catholics or Orthodox Christianity idea of what
Christianity was. And they believe that they were interacting with angels. Okay.
Non-human intelligences. So if you look back and you see muses, you know,
you can contextualize them within this tradition.
And so when I started to talk to people who were actually in the space program
and who were in these programs that now the government has said, Oh yeah,
we do have these programs. And they have the same belief structures.
They believe that they were also in contact with these non-human intelligences.
And they were getting what they call downloads of information and creating
sometimes with Tyler D and my book,
creating technologies that were real, and they were selling them on NASDAQ for,
you know, a lot of money, like, you know,
say a hundred million dollars or something like that, undisclosed amounts. Um,
but a lot.
And these things are viable technologies that we use now and,
and they make our lives better. And we progress as a species because of them.
Now that has nothing to do with the scientific method, as much as I know,
as much as anybody's going to get angry at me for saying that, but, you know,
sorry,
there's were strange encounters that created our ability to
go into space. I don't know if they're real or not,
but these people believed they were real.
Right. So there there's a,
they have a power in actually having an impact in this world, in,
um, in inspiring humans to create technology,
which enables us to do things we haven't been able to do before. Yeah.
And I like how we were putting like angels
alien life forms, aliens and technology,
all in the non-human intelligence camp, which I,
I really liked that because this that's very true.
It's this other source of all wisdom
intelligence, maybe a connection to.
The mysterious. Yes. I was really surprised by it.